suppose we lived forever
[Music]
one practical problem
if everyone born never dies in the early
days of our country there were only
about four million people and though we
reported last year that the world's
population grew by a hundred million
and if people keep making babies
then earth's population will rapidly
outstrip the resources to support it
so the day we stop dying must also be
the day we find another orb to
accommodate our overproduction of
air-breathing humans
this need for extra planets will never
cease
but the universe is vast
and just in our small sector of the
galaxy the catalogs are now rising
through 5 000 known exoplanets
we just need to invent terraforming
technologies in either warp drives or
wormhole transportation systems
and all will be fine
but why do we long to live forever
we want to live forever because we fear
death
we fear death because we are born
knowing only life
[Music]
yet we don't fear having never been born
while it's surely better to be alive
than dead
it's even better to be alive at all than
to not ever exist
religion through the ages has offered
detailed accounts for what happens after
death
for some it includes what happened
before you were born
a basic tenet of reincarnation
science doesn't have much to say about
valhalla or elysium
or hades or heaven or hell or the
spirits of your ancestors
the methods and tools of science do
however make cold concrete statements
about what happens when you die
[Music]
upon death there is no evidence that you
experience the consciousness you enjoyed
while alive
the electrochemical source of all your
thoughts feelings and sensory awareness
of the universe
your brain
which normally lights up an mri
becomes starved of oxygen we know that's
you disappearing because people who
experience a series of ultimately fatal
strokes
tragically and systematically lose
function of their mind and body
as they descend into a state of
non-existence
that's not as odd as it sounds
were you conscious before you were
conceived
did you complain where am i
how come i'm not on earth
no
you simply didn't exist
and if you're lucky to be born
your non-existence before life
bookends your non-existence after death
[Music]
consider that humans
are typically conceived in the single
most intimate act of human affection
we then gestate in utero for nine months
suckle for another 12 months
and require continual care through our
toddler years
afterward
humans attend elementary school to learn
reading writing and arithmetic
in middle school and high school we also
learned biology chemistry
maybe physics
we read works of literature
we learn history and the arts might even
play sports
lifelong friendships germinate from
these activities
we may also learn languages spoken by
other humans around the world
we participate in all the seasonal
rituals that we retain in modern society
as a binding force that brings us
together
adulthood arrives
21 years go by
at a speed of 30 kilometers per second
earth completed 21 orbits around the sun
a total of 20 billion kilometers through
space
all along
humans
invent refine and perfect anti-personnel
weapons such as land mines assault
rifles missiles and bombs
any one of which can end a life in an
instant
wars have taken a staggering and tragic
toll on human life since
pre-civilization
yet even excluding organized armed
conflict humans find reasons to murder
other humans at a rate that exceeds 400
000 per year
yes
worldwide humans commit homicide more
than a thousand times per day
do you know
do you really know
how precious life is
the total number of people who have ever
been born is about 100 billion
yet the genetic code that generates
viable versions of us is capable of at
least 10 to the 30th variations that
astronomically huge number is a 1
followed by 30 zeros
providing a million trillion
trillion possible souls
run through them all and eventually we
end up with you again or at least your
twin
but that won't happen anytime soon
so far our branch of the tree of life
has produced no more than
zero
.000
zero zero zero zero zero zero zero zero
zero zero zero one percent
of all possible humans
forcing the conclusion
that most people who could ever exist
will never even be conceived
each of us
for all practical purposes is unique in
the universe
[Music]
now and forever
being alive is the time to celebrate
being alive
every waking moment
all along the way
why not strive to make the world a
better place today than yesterday
simply for the privileged of having
lived in it
on my deathbed i'd be sad to miss the
clever inventions and discoveries that
arise from our collective human
ingenuity
presuming the systems that foster such
advances remain intact
that's what fueled the exponential
growth of science and technology in my
lifetime
i'd further wonder whether
civilization's arc of social progress
will continue
with all its fits and starts
and thus reward any time traveler from
the oppressed spectrum of humanity who
chose to visit the future
rather than the past
on the whole i don't fear death
instead i fear a life where i could have
accomplished more
an epitaph worthy of a tombstone
comes from the 19th century educator
horace mann
i beseech you to treasure up in your
hearts
these my parting words
be ashamed to die
until you have won some victory for
humanity
our primal urge to keep looking up
is surely greater than our primal urge
to keep killing one another
if so then human curiosity and wonder
the twin chariots of cosmic discovery
will ensure that starry messages
continue to arrive
these insights compel us for our short
time on earth
to become better shepherds of our own
civilization
yes life is better than death
life is also better than having never
been born
but each of us is alive against
stupendous odds
we won the lottery
only once
we get to invoke our faculties of reason
to figure out how the world works
we also get to smell the flowers
we get to bask in divine sunsets and
sunrises
and gaze deeply into the night skies
they cradle
we get to live
and ultimately die
in this glorious universe
[Music]
you